so going into creating content we want  to first of all define your brand  and this is where it's really important  to get this down very clearly  because if you don't understand who  you're creating content for  it's going to be a lot harder for tick  tock to define who  they should be serving your content to  so for skill bank what we broke  our brand into is a why statement and  then also our user persona  our why statement is to motivate and  empower individuals to define their own  path  so that they can empower others to  define theirs  and our user persona is people that are  interested in entrepreneurship  people that are self-starters and people  that are really interested  in marketing